this is our personal archive footage
that we are sharing with the world
[Music]
can you believe we got married three
times
it's like choosing a child I can't pick
the best one Vegas was like our Wild
Rock Star wedding
[Music]
Santa Barbara was like as traditional as
like everybody else's wedding could have
been do we say
Italy was just really romantic and
classic
felt like I had so much anxiety oh I
feel like shaky because it's such a
vulnerable moment you're sharing I just
felt like I'm about to marry like the
love of my life and then it was like oh
my God I'm about to marry the love of my
life and then it all set in
we provided the feeling and the vibe and
then really trusted Dominico to like
carry it out we wanted it to feel
authentic
I was nervous and I knew I'm not going
to be able to say my vows without crying
there's really no love story like you
guys
our wedding felt like time didn't exist
and it just felt perfect
[Music]